bonjour à tous on parle beaucoup souvent
de smartphones cher de smartphones très
haut de gamme
là je vais vous parler d'un smartphone
qui est globalement pas très cher et qui
est fait par un fabricant qui s'appelle
et l'ong global et on en parle plus
on est aujourd'hui au mwc à barcelone
alors respectivement ici il ya beaucoup
de monde beaucoup de fabricants
impliquant très connu il ya aussi
effectivement du fabricant peu connu en
tout cas pas encore connue en france
notamment beaucoup de fabricants chinois
la marque hello 'mobile' effectivement
une marque qui n'est pas du tout inconnu
en france et pourtant ils ont une gamme
qui est hyper complète avec des produits
qui en tout cas sur papier ont l'air
assez séduisant et l'agent bien devant
moi qui s'appelle le cac 50 le cac 50
c'est cette petite bête qui a tout d'un
grand
sauf le prix puisqu'il coûte 140 dollars
pour l'instant c'est un produit qui
n'est pas encore disponible en france si
on le veut il faut le faire venir
directement mais bon sur le papier en
tout cas
et bien c'est des gens dont ce qu'on va
faire on va regarder un peu la fiche
technique et puis après moi je dirai ce
que j'en pense ça smartphones qui est un
grand écran 6 pouces au format 18 9e ça
de toute façon les formats dix neuvième
qui sont vraiment imposé en 2010 est
donc continuer en 2018 c'est une dalle
ip sc du fhd en 1440 par 720 pixels
côté protection vous avez un gorilla
glass 4 sur le devant en arrière vous
avez ici le petit bouton pour le
déverrouiller double appareil photo ici
13 mégapixels et 5 mégapixels j'ai
absolument aucune info sur l'ouverture
après de toute façon sera smartphones de
ce prix pas s'attendre non plus à voir
des appareils de ligne à l'avant vous
avez une caméra 8 mégapixels
il est disponible en trois versions vous
l'avez ce mois en 16 giga de stockage et
2 gigas de ram 32 gigas du stockage 3
giga de ram ou 64 giga de stockage et 4
gigas de ram mais toutes sont android 7
mois un nougat
il devrait pouvoir être monté sur oreo
la version 8.0 dans très peu de temps
il a une batterie 3380
milliampères heures et vous retrouvez un
processeur oak d'accord soit du 1 5 ghz
soit du 2 5 giga hertz particulièrement
priori y aurait deux versions plus
d'infos tout de suite en tout cas
côté dimensions il fait 155 pas 74 par 9
points 8 mm il est assez épais assez
massif côté connectique c'est du micro
usb il effectivement du bluetooth du
wifi iv sur la 3g et la 4g
je sais pas s'il est compatible en
france si on peut le connecter aux
banques françaises et est disponible en
trois coloris orange marron et noir côté
design il ya un côté je sais pas trop
j'hésite entre d'un côté un peu sympa un
peu travaillé sur cuir il ya un côté un
peu kitsch rococo dit non à vous ce que
vous en pensez
moi je sais pas quoi en penser j'ai dit
trouve que le côté négatif c'est qu'il
est un peu épais vous avez ici un côté
qui est un peu épais le dos bon pourquoi
pas aller ça fait là faire le grand
écran 6 pouces c'est pas mal
la prise en main est bien cessibilité
derrière au boute en train de
verrouiller et pas mal je trouve
qu'après il fait le job
il est bien fait c'est pas non plus un
truc ce fou furieux mais c'est pas mal
voilà peu pour ce produit chinois je
voulais effectivement vous en parler
dites-moi est-ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que c'est toutefois un produit
qui pourrait vous intéresser si cette
marque arrivée en france
est ce que vous seriez susceptible
d'être intéressé par ce genre produit il
ya effectivement plein de produits qui
viennent de chine
ici au mwc forcément on sait que le
coeur de fabrication est situé là bas
donc forcément il est normal que tous
les fabricants chinois venaient ensuite
venir se positionner en france j'ai une
discussion en off avec 1
avec un des grands fabricants de
smartphones qui disait que de toute
façon le curseur pour les marques
chinoises c'est le huawei dès lors que
vous voyez arrive aux 10% de part de
marché c'est un signal très positif pour
les autres fabricants pour arriver et
c'est à ce moment là qu'ils arrivent et
qui se positionne son marché pour
l'instant volé en france représente à
peu près 9 % de part de marché ils sont
presque 10% donc il se peut qu'il
dissipe très très très peu de temps on
voit arriver tous les autres fabricants
chinois arrivé en france le signal c'est
que pour eux le marché est mûr donc
dites moi si vous vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter
est-ce que vous pensez que le marché est
mûr est ce que vous vous êtes mûr pour
aller sur un produit chinois marquis
moto sans commentaire comme d'habitude
zabita nes et des jolis pousse à vous
abonner parce qu'on va parler toujours
plus de produits tech ce soit des
smartphones contre qui nous vend plein
de choses qui arrivent
marc qui m'a tout ça on reste connectés
je vous dis à très bientôt jalousie
[Musique]